[MUSIC PLAYING]
GAURAV CHAUDHARY: Hi, my name is
Gaurav Chaudhary, better known
as Technical Guruji
to the internet.
[SPEAKING HINDI] I come
from India, living in Dubai.
I've been making YouTube
videos since October 2015.
I make two videos every day,
making videos in the flight,
on the beach, in the
mountains, on the streets,
every day without fail.
I just decided to use
this power of YouTube
to share some of
my tech knowledge
to the masses in
India in a way that
is very easy to understand.
So I just started creating
tech videos in Hindi.
Talking with Google I/O, it
is always a huge excitement.
[CROWD CHEERING]
I mean, this is the day when we
expect some new, crazy things
to happen.
Getting updates on
all the new projects
directly from the Google
team-- and of course,
all the development around
Android-- always charges me up.
This year at I/O 2018, I plan
to experience it all in person.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]